let's go show me
citizens room I just start going
yourself oh okay
today we're gonna cover the second of
the two methods of a transport of this
topic now just to jog your memories okay
the whole idea of integration in the
area isn't under church law really the
two ways of approximating area so the
first way was on leave this way which
one is home you know Mickey rectangles
out of this area and then you're ready
to these smart features take that area
take those bunch of rectangles and
usually people like I think to get an
exact area okay
I mean that yesterday was trapezoidal
rule which is taking an area using a
trapezium to get in a bowl top okay no
rectangles trip easier actually top by
the way is this trapezium the
disadvantage for them in terms of using
them to approximate areas under curves
compose and the problem is they don't
have jobs they are straight okay now how
many kinds of shapes do we know with
curse that we know how to work out the
area circle and and so that comes
basically 36 polygons
you said today it's not your days days
would be surprisingly not useful to me
when I try and work out the area under a
curve we will get to volume right now
but it's basically so basically so now
as soon as you can like do certain lot
of circles that kind of thing like that
kind of looks like a segment yes but you
start to have a think about the knots to
undo probably goods like meet you
measuring cycles Radian measure okay it
is what you want problems what so here's
one when you go occur very much like
he's my boy as a better way to get
anything at this area with a good shake
now the simplest kind of cliche officer
do we know that it's a parabola okay now
how would you use the parabola how would
you like we sort of get because you'd
make a bunch of rectangles okay or you
make a trapezium or bunch of trapezium
okay but how would you put a parabola
all I'm taking a lot of shape like this
so this is log X okay and I said before
that it can be integrated but it's kind
of it's hard to do you need more
sophisticated metals so can we get
approximation
okay well we've been talking that
function value so far right so here for
instance I've got two function values
and that would be all I need to make one
trapezium okay
but I'm gonna need more than just these
two function values to draw a parabola
that's going to be close to this kind of
area Quentin why where am I going to
need more than just these two
what you think about I'll get back to
her let's see these seven were you right
you're right you learned that if I give
you any three points okay you should be
able to draw a circle and over the water
that goes through those three points can
you tell me why it's an array that's
what you're like yes but you need a you
need a court property to use the
construction if you imagine you know
these three points is gonna be
interesting conference right if you make
that record early make another call MSA
yeah okay
the perpendicular bisector of a chord
should go through the center of the
circle right so if I draw a
perpendicular bisector like say like so
there's one okay where those two
perpendicular bisectors meet for to be
the center and there's only one of them
right it doesn't meet anywhere else it
can't possibly be anywhere else okay so
then I think if you remember under
construction to eat compass out you're
talking about there because that's the
center and then you should be able to
measure out all those distances should
be the same because they all should be
radiant right and then off your Center
goes along well
now the rabbits are the same okay now I
wonder if you can think about why look
at the dresser but you need three points
to uniquely define a problem just like
you need three points to uniquely
defined
okay obviously if I just had two points
these two okay
I couldn't draw not just a few but I
never even a number of parabolas that
all posture is better two points and
some of them will look nothing like
soccer so I need one more point from the
main point okay now what value does that
correspond to on the x-axis how about
kind of funny before I want the weight
not the distance between them all right
so I'm going to take the average right
now that corresponds to do something now
I bought three function values okay now
if I can draw a parabola that goes
through these and you'll need to get
your own maybe he forgot about a color
what would it look like
well I'm guessing I went through these
three it but there's something like this
now this trouble if you think about it
right to the left and to the right
all of interval it looks nothing like
the function that I'm actually trying to
approximate right but I don't care why
not
yeah every pot I'm interested in we use
the interval where I'm trying to work
out the area then in between animates
okay so even this pot like if I raise
all the rest of this you're like yeah
that's up that's a pretty decent
approximation yes it might even be close
up if you actually draw the actual
problem sir
now what I've got is a parabola that
goes through those three points and I
want to work out its area and step
underneath this I want you to dry
yourself with you set of axes but on
this one because I've chosen log X right
it just go there's no positive side this
time we're going to need some area over
here as well show you mine
okay so now I'm saying that this area
which is my exact ever talked about that
it should be approximately equal to this
area and this is enough this is a
parabola it's a completely different
shape okay but in between to all that
I'm interested in it's pretty close
right I could go ahead it's not everyone
campus area if I can use the integration
to see where it takes me
okay but before I do that right all I'm
trying to do is work at this area and I
want to make it as simple as possible
that's one of these methods of
approximation okay so if I can work out
an equivalent area which is
algebraically simpler to work out
tonight as well right because we're make
them notice easier and I'll get the same
value not the end a definite integral
and area it's just a number yes I just
want to get to the end result so we have
a look at this right hemisphere to can
be it kind of Missy different values
right now I can move this around to
different places in a variety of ways I
could do this but to save you a bit of
time okay the easiest place to move it
is to translate to the origin so if I
move this midpoint that a plus B onto if
I move that so it's sitting on the
y-axis I'll get a new area okay so I'm
just moved in at us so I haven't changed
its size in any way but it's gonna be
easier for me to calculate no where are
all of these places okay
usually we times whatever would be
calling the these subintervals
right I want to would be calling their
height H yeah so I'm gonna stick with
that convention that age
we'll actually have to get that now
those distances are H where are my usual
oneness right where are my new values
where I'm going to get the function
value minus H and H right because
they're your left and right all the
access to minus H and agent zeros in the
middle okay now let me just stop to make
sure you know what we're doing right
I've done two geometric treats you to
make things simple thing for me before
so that I've been observed mess up your
phone
taro a lot number one I've used a proud
okay that's my first geometric trick
number two I move the problem so it's
somewhere where it's gonna be nice and
neat for me okay from here is there's
nothing really else that I can do in
terms of geometric trickery
I'm done now I just have to cover the
algebra okay so now that I have to
figure out a lot I'm gonna give this
someone parabola a name since it's a
parabola and this is every corner hey
okay
now I don't learn what parabola it is so
I have to give it any of the general oh
it could be anything right depending on
what function we field okay now you'll
notice I've got capital ABCD why is that
because I'm already got my lower abs the
balance of don't this is not confusing
with each other yes yeah so this area
underneath my X is approximately equal
to this area under this parabola and
this problem is the same but there
importantly
okay it it will be exact in two cases
number one if it's if what I'm
approximating is itself a parabola right
cuz you replace a problem when you
travel off to get sympathy now the two
interestingly if you have a cubic
function and have a look at this after
we derive this ago if you start with
acute function and you approximated with
a parabola
you'll get the exact area back that's
interesting if you can work out why that
is with the regulator
but if it is in any other kind of
function okay if it's uh if it's uh a
lot of function and exponential if it's
a hyperbola anything else like that you
get close but they'll always be a little
bit of error you cannot exactly match up
the curvature so there will be a okay
all right now so I remember what's up
this is my parabola down okay so can't
work out what is the area underneath
this okay let me get rid of this one
I don't want to back out what is why
can't say this area is exactly equals to
you you know from A to B all okay but
now I'm going to change it much the same
way as with substitution is why we did
that first okay I'm going to say the
area is approximately equal to now the
boundaries and a function I'll have but
change I'm still with respect to X
though because it still is pretty bad
right so one of my key boundaries